raketenterror in Kiefer und wir wollen
direkt zu unserem Kollegen Paul
ronsheimer nach Kiew schauen denn er hat
Vitali Klitschko den Bürgermeister von
Kiew
ja ich stehe hier mit Vitali Klitschko
dem Bürgermeister von Kiew an dem
Spielplatz Krater mitten auf einem
Spielplatz ist gestern hier eine Rakete
eingeschlagen Vitali was geht einem da
durch den Kopf wenn man das hier sieht
wir befinden uns in genau historische
Mitte in unserer Stadt und
das daneben ist unsere Uni Universität
hauptunion ist sehr Trotte Uni das ist
historische Gebäude hier eine
Kinderspielplatz
in unserer Park
es geht
Studien spricht über hochprinzessige
Waffen und die hat gezielt an unsere
Kinder an unsere Zivilisten hier wenn er
wenn Russen sprechen ob er die
Kampf gegen radikalen Faschisten gegen
spezielle Produktion gegen ukrainische
Militär das ist eine alles Lügerei das
ist der Kampf gegen normale Zivilisten
Putin braucht keine ohne Ukraine jetzt
erleben wir Angriffe auf die zivile
Infrastruktur auch auf Wärmekraftwerke
und so weiter wie groß ist die Gefahr
dass Kiew das andere Städte im Winter
ohne Wärme ohne ja Heizung da stehen
könnten
das ist unsere
Serien Menschen zu geben Elektrizität
Wasser Heizung das ist so wichtig für
uns und die Risiko besteht besteht jetzt
im Moment mit Raketen und Griffe und
deswegen wir
bitten wir würden von unserer Partner
wir brauchen eine spezielle Systeme an
direkettensystemen in unserer Stadt weil
er bis heute die Sicherheit die
Hauptrolle spielt für jede Anwohner von
unserer Stadt und unseres Land was muss
passieren dass solche Bilder das so ein
Krater mit Ali dass das nicht mehr
möglich ist mitten in der Innenstadt in
Kiew Deutschland hat ja angekündigt dass
man etwas schicken will aber das ist
bislang nie angekommen also zumindest
dass ihre System
wir brauchen dieses Systemen und wir
brauchen schutzen unsere Bürger und wenn
es möglich wir bieten an unsere Partner
solche Systeme an uns zu schicken was
will Putin damit erreichen was er gerade
tut denn militärisch gewinnt er damit ja
nicht an der Front gewinnt weiter in die
Ukraine was soll das bringen was er hier
tut dieser Terror er versucht das ist
eine Panik zu bringen das ist vorbei
verbringen the house in unserer Land
statt dem
ohnehin schon entsprechend viele
Menschen die Menschen hat eine Wut gegen
russische Aggression gegen Putin und
wollen unser Land zu verteidigen wir
wollen nicht fliegten wir wollen hier
leben in eine friedliche Land in
friedliche Stadt und solche Aktivitäten
bringt noch mehr Wut und
genau das andere was erwartet Putin das
ist wir bleiben hier wir werden kämpfen
wir wollen unsere Zukunft beteiligen was
bedeutet es wenn Wladimir Putin auch
heute morgen wieder zuschlägt wir haben
auch wieder hier
Luftalarm gehört in Kiew in saporisha
gab es Luftalarm ist zu erwarten dass
diese Terrorwelle wie gestern weitergeht
oder hat er nicht genügend Raketen die
euch so treffen können wie gestern ich
bin keine
Experte in den Bereich aber die
militären und Experte sagen das ist die
er hat nicht viele Raketen bleibt nicht
viel übrig und auch hat sie riesige
Probleme mit seinem Militär seine
professionelle Armee schafft das nicht
und deswegen er macht eine
wie man das
macht die neue
die Zivilisten sammelt sie jetzt im
Moment gegen Ukraine zu kämpfen und wir
spüren und wie bekommen Informationen
der Russe und wolle nicht kämpfen die
langsam die Prozesse laufen und die
Stellen die Frage wieso Russland wird
langsam isoliert wie so eiserner Vorhang
kommt wieder wieso die
Russen nicht willkommen in die ganze
Welt wieso Sanktion kommen das ist
gerade eine Wirkung und das ist leider
dauert bisschen längere aber trotzdem
auf jeden Fall die Serie die jede
russische Familie wird seine Frage
stellen und Putin nehmen um russische
Regierung wieso ist mein Bruder mein
Sohn mein Sohn mein bekannte verwandeln
ist gestorben wo ist die Grund von diese
sinnlose Krieg gleichzeitig gibt es
Debatten auch in Deutschland und in der
Welt bei der Frage soll jetzt verhandelt
werden es gibt Kritik auch an silensky
der das ja ausgeschlossen hat der gesagt
hat mit Putin kann man nicht mehr
verhandeln wie siehst du das das ist
komisch zu hören das ist wie fühlen wir
uns als Geiseln ja die Putin hat dann
nixiert die große Teil von unserer
Territorium und hat so viele Menschen
umgebracht und jetzt sagt so lass uns
Kompromisse finden lasst uns zu sprechen
denke ich mal die einzige Kompromisse
wir sind bereit zu sprechen aber wenn
die letzte russische Soldaten verlassen
unsere Territorium herzlichen Dank
Vitali Klitschko Bürgermeister von Kiew
heute hier an diesem Tag am Tag nach dem
das passiert ist wir wollen noch einmal
drauf schauen hier was hinter Vitali
Klitschko zu sehen ist dieser
Kindergarten attackiert von der
russischen Armee und damit zurück nach
Berlin
[Musik]